Hello. This is 6 Minute.
English from BBC
Learning English.
I'm Neil. And I'm Beth.
How old are you, Beth?
That's a very
personal question, Neil!
Sorry. I didn't mean to be rude.
Anyway, at least you're not a centenarian -
someone who's lived to be
a hundred years old.
Are you saying I look a hundred?
That's even ruder!
Sorry, Beth.
No, it's just that,
with advances in modern medicine,
people are living longer and longer.
There was a time when living
to 100 seemed impossible.
But in 2021,
The United Nations Population
Division estimated there to be
over half a million centenarians
worldwide
and that number is set to rise.
So, how do you live to 100?
And what could life be like
in your twilight years?
A phrase meaning your old age
or the last years of your life.
That's what we'll be discussing
in this programme and of course,
we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary, too.
But first,
I have a question for you, Beth.
In 2022
The world's oldest certified person
died aged 119,
but which country was she
from? Was it:
a) Switzerland b) Italy or c) Japan.
Hmm, I think the answer is Japan.
OK Beth, we'll find out the answer
at the end of the programme.
Of all the many factors for long life,
such as diet, exercise and keeping
active, human relationships are among
the most important. People
who are more connected with others and
have warmer relationships, live longer
and stay healthier, and according
to psychiatrist Robert Waldinger,
talking here with the BBC
World Service Programme
'The Inquiry', those relationships
don't necessarily have to be with humans.
Introverts actually find having
a lot of people around stressful,
so they might only need one or two
close people and that's all they need,
that's all they want.
And that's just fine for them.
So, one size doesn't fit all
when it comes
to how many relationships
you need to have a healthy life.
It doesn't have to be done
with another human.
We know that pets provide us
with a great deal of comfort and joy
and pets can calm us down.
Whether you're a shy introvert
or noisy extrovert,
what counts is friendship,
be that with a human or a pet. Different
things work for different people.
So, Dr Waldinger
says it's not 'one size fits all' - a phrase
meaning something which is suitable
for everyone or every purpose.
So far, we've mentioned the importance
of diet, exercise and friendship.
But some people want
more radical ways of defying death
and staying young. Dr Nir Barzilai
director of the American
Federation for Ageing Research
has developed three scenarios in his
work with centenarians in the US.
The first scenario, called
Dorian Gray
after the fictional character
who didn't age
involves delaying the ageing process.
Here's doctor Barzilai
explaining more to BBC
World Service Programme.
'The Inquiry'.
The second scenario is
what we call the 'wolverine'
or the 'fountain of youth' taking
old people and make them young.
This is very, very hard.
This will be
the most complex things we can do.
And the third scenario,
and this is a very exciting scenario,
and we have some evidence that
it works, is the 'Peter Pan' scenario.
Peter Pan, didn't grow
old - the idea that you'll take people
when they're 20 or 30
and give them a treatment
every few months or every year and
you'll basically erase their ageing
and let them age
very, very slowly,
which also will mean, probably.
that they'll pass
their 115 year,
maximum potential lifespan.
All Dr Barzilai's treatments are aimed
at extending lifespan, the length
of time someone is normally expected
to live. His second treatment,
making someone who is old,
younger, is called 'the fountain
of youth', a legendary source
of magical water that keeps
anyone who drinks it, young forever.
Doctor Barzilai's third treatment involves
slowing down the ageing process
so much that people hardly age at all.
This treatment is called Peter Pan
after the fictional boy who never grew
up and is connected to another idiom,
'Peter Pan Syndrome',
which describes an immature person
who has reached adulthood,
but refuses to take on
adult responsibilities.
But which country was the
certified oldest person in the world
from? That was your question, Neil and
I guessed Japan. But was I right?
You were... correct!
Kane Tanaka, was born
on the Japanese island of Kyushu.
She lived to 119,
the oldest human ever recorded,
and her secret? Playing chess
eating chocolate and drinking coffee!
OK, let's recap the vocabulary
we have learned
from this programme about 'centenarians'
- people aged
100 years or more.
Your 'twilight years' are your old age.
The phrase 'one size fits all' means suitable
for everyone or every purpose.
A 'lifespan' is the length of time
someone is normally expected to live.
The legendary 'fountain of youth'
produces magical water,
so that anyone who drinks
it lives forever.
And finally, the phrase
'Peter Pan syndrome' describes an adult
who refuses to grow up. Once again,
Our 6 minutes are up.
Join us again soon for more
useful vocabulary here at 6 minute
English. Goodbye for now.
Bye!